- Our next guest had her breakout role
as Echo in the Disney
Plus series "Hawkeye..."
I love "Hawkeye."
A few years ago.
Now she's got her own series.
It's named after her character, Echo,
and you can also see it on Disney Plus,
say hello to Alaqua Cox, everybody.
(audience cheering)
So everybody, let's welcome Ashley.
This is Alaqua's interpreter.
Welcome Ashley as well.
(audience applauds)
This is Common.
I'm gonna introduce you to Common.
[Ashley] Nice to meet you.
- Great to meet you, blessings.
- So you're a new mama, right?
So how's that like?
- Yes.
I'm a new mom to a three month old son.
- Oh, you must be are tired.
- He just became three months
old a few days ago.
Oh my gosh, he's growing so fast.
I can't believe it, that
time does actually fly.
I truly believe that quote now.
- Absolutely. Are you tired? (laughs)
- [Ashley] At first, yes.
He probably woke me up four
or five times a night in the beginning.
But now he's gotten better with sleeping,
so I am very fortunate.
I don't wanna jinx it now though.
- [Kelly] We're gonna... Here you go.
That's not wood, there we go.
(Common laughs)
- Yeah, no, don't jinx it.
So motherhood, what do you
feel like has surprised you?
Did you always wanna be a mother?
- [Ashley] I've always wanted to be a mom.
I always wanted many, many kids.
But now with my career,
I think I might keep it to one or two.
- Yeah, solid move.
(Common and Kelly laugh)
That's what I say. (chuckles)
So how do you go... You
grew up in Wisconsin.
How does one go from
growing up in Wisconsin
to all of a sudden on "Hawkeye?"
- [Ashley] My gosh, I
get this question a lot,
but it's just a cool story that I have.
I never had acting on my radar before.
A friend of mine sent me the call casting
for a deaf indigenous
woman in their twenties.
And at first I was apprehensive,
but then I got the same
text from two other friends
and I thought, "Ooh, there's
no way I'm gonna get it."
Because her character Maya
does not have an amputated leg.
So I thought there's no
way they would hire me.
And three months later I auditioned,
got the role, and here we are now.
I was so surprised.
(audience applauding)
- It's an amazing story.
How do you feel like
this role has an impact
with the indigenous communities and also,
anybody wanting to achieve this dream
that has prosthetics, maybe feel like
they won't get hired for that?
I mean, you're representing
so many people right now.
- [Ashley] It feels like
a huge honor to be able
to represent all these
underrepresented communities.
I want kids to be able to see
themselves and feel worthy.
We deserve this space in this moment.
I am so happy Hollywood
is making these changes
and accommodations for us.
It's a great time to live right now.
- Absolutely, I love that.
A positive outlook on it too.
(audience applauding)
So what you feel like,
Common, you're an actor,
you do all the things,
you win all the awards.
What do you feel like you've done
that has had a huge social
impact, obviously "Glory."
- Well, yeah, I mean, I think
being a part of "Glory,"
the film "Selma," it
really was just bigger
than John and I, or Ava DuVernay.
We all collectively put our
hearts and souls into it,
but it became something that was more
of a movement and it
raised the consciousness.
And I always look at those awards as like,
these are things that allow
me to do more of the work.
So I'm grateful for
them, I'm very grateful.
And I'll receive them, but I
feel like anytime I get one,
I gotta do more for the
people. That's how I feel.
- Yeah, well, 'cause you have
the chance...
(audience applauding)
Not everybody gets that opportunity.
So explain for everybody
that hasn't seen "Hawkeye,"
explain Echo and her powers.
- [Ashley] I love Echo.
She's such a cool character.
She's deaf, indigenous, of course.
And an amputee, we added that in.
I always love that we can
add that to my identity.
But she's strong, she's
brave, she's fearless.
She's a competitor and her powers,
they are culturally
related with each other.
So she uses her powers from her ancestors.
It's so crazy to see myself
on the screen behind me.
So sorry about that, but
Echo is a very cool person.
- I mean, you look badass.
I'd be like, "That's me."
"That's me. I did that."
Well, everybody, here is a
look at Alaqua Cox and Echo.
(metal and palms thudding)
(intense instrumental music)
(Echo grunts)
(foot thuds)
(metal clangs)
(intense instrumental music)
(fist and foot thuds)
(fence clangs)
(metal clangs)
(intense instrumental music)
(audience applauds)
- That one kick you held up
there, and then said 'no.'
- That was crazy.
- [Ashley] Yeah, oh my god.
Can you imagine the pain? My leg is metal.
If I hit somebody in the face,
that would be so painful.
But my older brother, when he was 16...
We are 16 months apart,
I would take off my leg
and literally hit him with it.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
- That's incredible.
- That was amazing, what she did.
- That was, oh my gosh.
- [Ashley] Oh gosh, thank you so much.
I appreciate that.
- [Kelly] Oh man, if I was ever gonna be
in a Marvel, if I was an actor,
I'd be like, "Which one is chill?"
(audience laughing)
Which one has the power of chill?
That doesn't have to do all that.
Well, everybody, "Echo"
streams on Disney+.
Be sure to check it out.